hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom it's been a little bit of a
while we took a week-long break last
week so hopefully everyone is doing well
for those of you who are new to this
this is something we started doing when
we started seeing the school closures
but it's really a way for all of us to
connect and talk about topics that are
both interesting and educational
addressed in education but beyond
education and we have really exciting a
guest from our Khan Academy team today
and we have an exciting set of
announcements there but before I get
into that I do like to remind folks that
kind of got to be is a not-for-profit
that we exist because of philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself and
so if you're in a position to donate
please think about doing so and special
thanks to several corporations that have
stepped up over the last several months
especially once we started having the
increased cost due to covin we were
already running at a deficit before
kovat and now our deficit has grown but
special thanks to Bank of America
google.org AT&T fastly and Novartis
their help has made a huge difference
but we're still running at a deficit so
anything that folks can do to help would
make a big difference with that I'm
really excited to introduce a colleague
of mine here at Khan Academy Lindsay
Spears who's a senior content senior
math content manager Lindsay good to see
you let me see each other well music
these days it's on zoom' a lot so tell
us a little bit about and just as a
reminder for everyone watching if you're
on YouTube or Facebook put questions we
have folks who are looking at it and
they'll surface it to myself and Lindsay
but Lindsay tell us the announcement
that we have made recently yeah so
really exciting we've built ten new
courses in a math courses that are
required are get ready for grade level
courses they start with third grade get
ready for third grade and go all the way
to get ready for precalculus and they're
built to help students who are going
into that upcoming course prepare for
that the course that they're headed into
the math course they're headed into and
why did we do this yeah we did this
because we know every year there's a
summer slide right students you lose a
little bit of what they've learned in
the
year over the summer but this year with
the school closures due to koban we knew
that was going to be even greater than
normal and we wanted to find a way to
help address that and so the courses are
really to help students let's say going
into fifth grade with here we know this
is the the content you're about to take
on in fifth grade and the topics you're
going to explore and to have a really
successful year with those topics here's
some skills that we think would really
help you prepare help you be ready to
take on those next topics so we built
smaller courses that really get you
ready for what you're about to learn in
level yeah this is this notion this is
this isn't a Kovan thing this is even
pre kovat kids you know we talk a lot
about it as their moves through kind of
a fixed pace system they inevitably
accumulate gaps and then you have things
like summer vacation where not only do
you not not only do not learn but you
often forget and some of and and and the
skills that you did know atrophy and
then those gaps that you have continued
to exist or maybe even get bigger that's
always an issue which is why we've
always talked about the value of
personalized learning being able to
learn at your own time and pace but this
year to your point it's likely to be
that much worse because some students
have been able to keep learning on say
Khan Academy while others haven't and so
this is these get ready for grade level
courses are way for students parents or
teachers working with those students to
make sure they have all of the
prerequisite skills up to and including
the grade level up to the grade level
work and then they can of course work on
at their own time in place and and I
mean this sounds we had Tim Vandenberg
on I guess we called this show we had
him on this show it seems like a
lifetime ago I think was about two
months ago now and you know he did
something similar with kind of Khan
Academy before to get ready for grade
level he had all of his sixth graders
90% of whom were at a below grade level
when they entered into his classroom he
had them all started at early learning
kindergarten level math and then go
through all of arithmetic on Khan
Academy which is a lot of skills and
he's seen really incredible gains with
those students they were not only able
to catch up to sixth grade they were
able to learn in sixth grade and many of
them ended up ahead of grade level how
is this different than what kid then
what
Tim Vandenberg hat does or has been
doing with his students yeah what Tim
does is so exciting starting all the way
back in kindergarten and going through
what slightly different about these
courses they're more focused just on the
one course you're about to go into so
they're really we really thought about
you know what does a seventh grade math
student take on what are the topics of
seventh grade math student learns and
built like a really custom set of
content and exercises and videos that
support that very specific grade so they
they fill the gaps just like Tim does
but they're filling a very personalized
or individualized set of gaps that we
know for that course so it's it's sort
of like a fast-tracked tim-tim model yep
so if I'm what's going on here is
essentially we want all teachers to be
able to do all students to be able to do
exactly what the students in Tim
Vandenberg's class does but Tim
Vandenberg was kind of using existing
things on Khan Academy and his students
maybe had to cover you know third grade
or fourth grade skills that don't
directly feed into the sixth grade and
so what we've essentially done is taken
Tim Vandenberg's
intent but we've streamlined it so that
teachers and students have a much better
chance of getting to grade level as
quickly as possible and how would you
recommend teachers do use it would you
say that they should have all their
students work on it for say the first
well they could use it over the summer
they could use it for the first several
weeks of the school year or should they
go you know do the the unit in the get
ready for grade level before they do the
corresponding unit in the grade level
course yeah I think there's a lot of a
couple different models that would work
well currently since we're in the summer
doing it during the full course in the
summer is a great way to build know that
if you have you know some time to spend
on math this summer these are the best
things to use that time on and you can
do the complete course over the summer
ahead of time for teachers during the
school year I think there's a lot of
value in doing it in line and so the way
we've built the course is each of the
units will say like in sixth grade get
ready for ratios because we know all
sixth graders
gonna spend a lot of their year learning
ratios so as the teachers preparing to
teach ratios to start that unit she or
he can use to get ready for ratios unit
you could even use them at the same time
you could you know simultaneously be
working on sixth-grade ratios while also
building those strong foundations to
support that learning or you could do it
one after the other so I think there's a
model where you could do the whole thing
upfront but really for teachers and
during the school year I think there's
an enormous advantage to doing it during
so that you're filling the gaps right at
the time those gaps are needing filling
and really getting to build the
connections between what you've learned
in earlier years and what you're
learning this year and to your point the
units in the get ready for grade level
course they're actually named so that
they line up nicely with units in the
grade level course so your point about
ratios which is a sixth grade there's a
unit in the sixth grade course about
ratios there's a unit in the get ready
for sixth grade course called getting
ready for ratios right yeah they pretty
much parallel there's a few units that
maybe it's brand-new to that year so
there may not be a get ready unit but in
general you should be able to do a
crosswalk between the get ready course
and the on grade course and they should
match up pretty nice neatly and what
your what would you say you know a lot
of teachers like well this sounds great
because every teacher we talked to knows
that kids come after a normal summer
with all sorts of gaps and this year is
going to be that much worse as we were
talking about but to a teachers like you
know I already have trouble covering all
of the grade level of material now
there's this whole other course that
seems ginormous because it's covering so
much material how do I do both is this
what's the size of this course relative
to the normal grade level course so the
size of these courses are somewhere
between like a third to a half of the
size of the regular course so they're
actually quite streamlined and smaller
than the on grade courses and it is
additional content and I certainly
remember that well from my time in the
classroom but we also I think sometimes
when you're filling the right gaps that
it actually accelerates the on grade
learning too so it might be additional
but it's the right additional that may
may make teaching the on grades
just go even more smoothly right and
we're seeing a screenshot looks like
this is our sixth grade course so there
would be a corresponding get ready for
sixth grade course down I was think to
your point these are shorter courses and
another element here is students in
theory if they're ready for grade level
should know a lot of this material so
they could probably use our acceleration
mechanics things like course challenges
unit tests mastery challenges quizzes to
accelerate through a lot of the material
pretty fast that's exactly right and on
this I can show you so this is our main
on grades sixth grade but just to show
how to get to the courses anywhere that
we are you are on Khan Academy up here
if you click on the courses but get
ready courses are listed right here so
we have our main math courses below it
but right here we have the get ready for
third fourth fifth six so if we click
into Orban go the main get ready page
and this has all of the different get
ready courses and if we click into one
um I'm just picking this first one here
we can see it's a bit smaller than the
the main ones this has 37 exercises to
try as opposed to the the main third
grade course which has over a hundred
different skills that you would do in
the on grade course and what do you
recommend you know speaking of
acceleration let's say you do an inline
so that you do the get ready for unit
right before or at the same time as the
corresponding unit at grade level would
you recommend teachers maybe leverage
like the unit tests I'm making stuff up
you know the kids take the unit test if
they're doing well on it if they get you
know 90 plus percent maybe they don't
even necessarily have to finish the get
ready for grade level but they could
probably finish it quite quickly but if
they get a lower score on the unit test
and that those students should be able
to go to the what they had gaps in yeah
that's right so they get accelerate in a
few ways you could take the course
challenge which would show you a variety
of skills from the entire get ready
course or if you really wanted to focus
on I really want you know to see are
they ready for place values my class
ready so if you went to the get ready
for place value unit and just did that
unit test it's going to show you either
some students they're ready they really
have all those foundational skills and
they're ready for on grade and if not
it'll help you identify it'll show the
different skills where they were not yet
successful and it'll help that student
say okay here's a few things in place
value that I need to go back to and get
some practice in so it will help them
identify help the teachers and and the
students identify if they're there
already you know ready for the
grade-level content or if there's a
little bit more work they could do to
prepare and there's a bunch of questions
coming in so from Facebook Robin
Schwartz asks what would you recommend
for raising a college freshmen who will
be a who will be in a summer academic
skills course is there a way to take to
take off the grade level get ready for
algebra one looks great I haven't I
think I'm I think what the question what
Robins asking is and I'm not maybe
asking about a family member or maybe
Robin is to college but you know if
someone's going to be a rising freshman
depending on what the rising freshman is
taking some freshman will take kind of a
college algebra course some of them will
take a precalculus or calculus course
do they have get ready for grade level
courses there we don't get ready for
grade levels specifically for the
college courses but I think the college
level algebra if you were gonna do get
ready for algebra one or get ready for
algebra two a combination of those would
probably be a great support for starting
a lot of college algebra level math
courses and they're just really going to
build that foundational algebra content
the base of all algebra understanding so
really beneficial to pretty much any
college course if you wanted to get some
practice in I think that would be a
great place to start
yeah I mean to your point college
algebra you know the course college
algebra is usually someplace it's
usually pretty analogous to algebra two
and a lot of places sometimes even a
combination of algebra 1 and algebra 2
so if you're getting ready for those
courses you are likely to be getting
ready for and what are the most advanced
to get ready so the gun ready courses
start at 3rd grade or 2nd grade start
the third grade but that goes blurry I
can great content and first you know
some first grade content and then it
goes all the way to get ready for
calculus is the highest that it goes up
to and that courses and include a lot of
content from algebra 1 and algebra 2 and
even a little bit of geometry until you
know going back to the to the question
is that you know a lot of students will
take a precalculus course and the
precalculus college course pretty much
is the precalculus high school course
and so that would be a valuable thing
too
for them for them to take so let's see
there so we already actually Cindy right
from Facebook asked the question that we
we just answered which is what grade
levels do they get ready courses cover
and and she says we love Khan Academy
well Cindy we love you too let's see we
have from Facebook any hole for Thompson
is this mat specific anything for
English and language arts these get
ready courses are math specific but we
are also building our main ela content
and so there is ela content even
including now elementary in middle
school on the site so there is great
content for ela practice which would
help you get ready for the school year
but they're not specifically to get
ready for grade level courses like we
have right now on that right and this is
something we've we've talked a lot about
inside the organization which is math
and ela are different they have some
similarities but there's different in
many ways which is in math you
definitely have these skills that very
clearly get built on in our
prerequisites for each other while in
ela there's kind of your background
knowledge there's your you know your
kind of your your your Lexile level that
you can read at and you can you can
sometimes grok something or understand
something i you see science fiction
terms that I shouldn't you grok
something from stranger in a strange
land to understand something deeply grok
something at a higher reading level then
it has some background knowledge that
you might not fully have you can still
sometimes engage in a text like that
while in math if you're looking at an
equation that has a negative exponent in
it and you don't understand negative
exponents you're just gonna be kind of
you're not gonna really have a shot so
that's why these get ready for grade
level courses are so relevant in math
especially absolutely the way the skills
in math spiral throughout the years yeah
really valuable to have those
foundational skills
yep so see there's more question so
actually another question from Robin
thanks this will be for an online class
do all students get the same exercises
Lindsey I could take a stab of it but I
think I have an answer to but I think
the exercises are the same and each get
ready for grade level but each student
won't see the same items so there's
those if two students are practicing and
get ready for ratios they're both gonna
see the same skills but they might see
different specific questions not sure
South that's how you're you are also
thinking that question
that's exactly right what you know
internally when we talk about exercises
we're talking about kind of a bucket of
items that are all addressing the same
standard or addressing the same skill
and so and one of the things and a lot
of folks don't realize that you know
there's there's like tools out there
that you know will give you some
practice but they're essentially you
know five questions that everyone sees
and if you tell your neighbor the answer
to question number two is C then they
know the answer C we spend a lot of time
and resources and Lindsay's team
especially we make far more items than
the student is likely to see so that
they can get as much practice as they
need in those skills and to Lindsey's
point students that are next to each
other they'll be working on the same
standards they'll be working on the same
skills not necessarily they could go
from forgetting to N and do it in the
same order but very often when they do
the mastery challenges they'll be
different even skills that are being
covered that are more relevant to what
that student needs to work on and when
they work on a given skill the actual
problems they see are there are likely
to be very likely to be dead different
than what their classmate sees but as a
teacher you get a skills report and then
if you do things like assignments you
can actually understand which items I
gave your your students the the most
difficult they mode which individual
questions which which can also be really
useful so let's see
similarly I might add that the student
was gonna if you're thinking about doing
this in the summer versus the school
year if you did these in the summer you
would likely see different items that
you saw in the school year even the same
student so you would be able to to use
this multiple times and still see a
variety of items even for one single
student yep now as I see from from
YouTube samoan cruz asks do you offer
certificates that would help motivate
the children after they complete the
course i don't know if we have
certificates but i do know that we're
running a camp con this summer which is
a program that's gonna have different
incentives and weekly learning
objectives built around these get ready
for grade level courses it starts today
actually launched today but you can join
anytime between now and i believe it
ends August 28th and there's a webinar
later in the week on Thursday about that
but there so there is a campaign around
it that I believe will have some
different incentives as students work
through it yeah exactly no camp Khan
disease you know the Gatorade for grade
level courses got launched at the end of
last week they're all live everyone can
do it and then Camp Khan is really a way
ideally if every child in the country or
the planet or I guess the universe were
to start learning this summer then
everyone would be ready for grade level
or unfactored they could finish the
course and then start on their grade
level course before they even get back
to school and and camp Khan to your
point and I'm very self-conscious about
we overuse this the whole Khan thing but
the butt camp Khan is is about that
exactly it's about motivating students
and families to engage over the summer
to learn and it is focused on the get
ready for grade level courses which you
and your team have have really done an
amazing job putting together it's useful
outside of this kovat strangeness that
we're dealing with but it's especially
useful right now when there's gonna be a
huge variance in students learning so
let's see Andres Torres from hundred
stories from YouTube would we would we
see in the future get ready courses for
college-level classes I I could take a
stab at it I mean I think if this is
well received yeah we would seriously
think about it
you know obvious
oculus stats even a lot of us the
science courses one could imagine I get
ready for course could be really really
really valuable I don't anything to add
to that Lindsay yeah completely agree
absolutely let's see from Facebook Mike
Ritchie says I had my son take the 4th
grade curriculum challenge of the course
challenge on your site and he's caught
in 97% it then had him answer six
mastery questions which he got right is
it safe to say that I can move him on to
the fifth grade curriculum I feel very
comfortable if that's how well you did
on the course challenge I think he's
probably ready to get 5th grade to try
and you know nothing is forever he moves
on to 5th grade and that's a real
struggle fourth grade is still there for
him you know we're always what we've
mastered and not changes all the time we
don't stay at a constant state of what
we remember so he could he could always
go back and revisit 4th grade but I
would feel very comfortable recommending
he to check out the fifth grade content
yeah and I completely agree with that
and Mike if your child is doing that
well in the fourth grade I actually
think I'd be intrigued you could even
start the fifth grade course challenge
as well I wouldn't be surprised if they
do quite well on that and then that can
help your child accelerate to the skills
and fifth grade that they might actually
that they need to focus on that they
haven't learned yet well some of it
either they might already know or they
might be able to into it yeah you know
they already know how to do you know
three digit multiplication and you know
I don't think those are those might be
you know the standards better than I do
Lindsay but you know in theory some of
the things you might be able to into it
so so yeah but but your but your and
your son or daughter I think it's very
very ready so let's see from Facebook
Matthew Tyler we have used Khan Academy
for years we're grateful that you are
still innovating great work well Matthew
I will say I mean one of the fun things
about having Lindsay here is I get a
disproportionate amount of the credit
but it's great to see you know now you
know the people other than Sal of which
most of Khan Academy is it was over 200
folks who are doing a lot of the heavy
lifting most of the heavy lifting for
making all of this possible so yes
and then next day you put me on being as
well let's see other questions here for
those of you who don't know what I'm
doing I'm this little Google Doc below
the window where I see Lindsey where I'm
seeing so Sofia Patel says how do I join
camp Khan and our team put a you'll URL
here
Felipe might be able to get it up on the
on the screen but it's Khan dotco are
they up on the screen cap Khan overview
well it's Khan dot Co slash camp Khan
2020 and I don't think capitalization
matters but at least on the the URL I'm
seeing the the sein camp is capitalized
and the K in Khan is capitalized conduct
Co / catcon 2020 and hopefully if you do
a web search for it you'll you'll be
able to you'll be able to go find it oh
and capitalization does matter so Khan
co / capital C amp capital K Han 2020 C
other questions
oh it's easy so Debbie Charlton from
Facebook is asking is cap Khan Eddie at
age level or just 12 years and above
camp that I believe it at any age level
Sammy built around the get ready courses
which started and get ready for third
grade so yeah that they should should
work for anybody getting ready for next
school year and math yeah let's see
there's another course and I actually
think it's a lot of mechanics or
actually the the motivation mechanics
it's really I think especially fun for
younger students you know I would say
ages 8 to I would say 1314 are probably
the students were going to get the most
out of like all of the the fun of camp
Khan I would I would like to believe
that also 14 or 15 year olds or 16 year
olds would also like enjoy it but I
would also like to believe that they
don't need all the fun motivation
because they are determined young adults
to master the skills they need
so there's one last question I see here
about do we have a course in
differential equations I'll say I'll
just say we do have a course in
differential equations that's from Kasab
bother I it does not have our
differential equations course right now
is just videos it does not have all of
the interactive exercises and course
challenges and mastery and everything
that Lindsey's been talking about but we
do have it's a little bit of an older
course I remember making it back in 2000
probably 2010 but it's there and people
still say that they find it useful so
hopefully you do as well let's see well
it looks like we're actually almost out
of time well Lindsey what what else does
the math team you know foreshadow for us
what else our might might be coming down
the pipeline yeah so the math team where
we're always you know working on the
existing courses improving the content
thinking of you know new ways we can
innovate to teach things different
strategies we can use well one thing
that could be coming we just heard about
differential equations not having
practice content currently there's
another course multivariable calculus
and now they're one of our higher level
courses that currently is all articles
and videos so learning as you know sort
of learning components but we are adding
practice components to that so now the
videos will have practice alongside
those those those videos where you can
you know do the videos and then check
for your understanding and do that and
do the practice problems interactive
piece as well so we are adding that in
one of our college-level courses so
maybe another one soon yeah that's very
exciting multivariable calculus and III
do think this is maybe there's other
resources in the area I think this is
frankly the only place where you're
going to be able to get mastery practice
you know we already have the videos in
multivariable calculus but it's going to
give you as much practice as you need to
understand that you've mastered it I'll
throw out some other foreshadowing you
know we have Lindsay and her team have
worked on things like learning plans for
the back end for the back several months
of last school year in the summer we're
definitely looking at can we create
learning plans which are really you know
if you're doing get ready for grade
level courses or grade level courses
what are reasonable goals for a student
you know what units should they complete
by what date in order to be on on pace
so that's something that we are
contemplating if we have the resources
to be able to do I'll also throw out and
actually Lindsay probably doesn't know
about this I always have to my own
little skunk work projects I I will do a
plug so there's a side project
it's a sow project right now it's not
officially Khan Academy but maybe one
day it will be if it gets off the ground
we call it we're calling it schoolhouse
dot world and the reason why I'm
mentioning it is obviously you can learn
on Khan Academy at your own time and
pace used to get ready for grade level
courses do the grade level courses but
many of you are wondering well can I get
tutoring but is there a place where
someone a live person could help me and
schoolhouse dot world is it's a it's
called an alpha it's a very nascent
experimental project where people can
sign up and it will pair people can run
group tutoring sessions on different
topics on Khan Academy with with
students who need it and they're
starting their folks any of y'all should
go to school hostile world and there's a
little registration form and they're
kind of letting people in as we have
enough teachers and we have enough
students and they're focused right now
in calculus because it seems like over
the summer there's a lot of students who
need help in calculus who I guess we're
preparing for the next school year and
so especially in calculus there's going
to be 22 classes for free by volunteer
teachers volunteer tutors in calculus
this week so go to the schoolhouse table
dot world if you want that and obviously
you could imagine a future where many
people are in school hostile world and
we're gonna be able to draw more bridges
between the Khan Academy world than that
but I'll throw that out as well so uh
Lindsay thanks so much for joining and
I'm very excited for for you know
hopefully a lot of people are going to
learn from the work that you and the
team have done thanks so much thanks for
having me well thanks everyone for for
joining as you can see you know the the
art of of management and leadership is
just hiring people that are smarter than
yourself and I I were to pray to myself
I think I'm I'm relatively good at that
so thanks so much for joining this
livestream and I look for
to seeing all of y'all tomorrow
you